START IN 50th GAME OF THE
SEASON,
>> BROOKS, ACROSS THE BLUE LINE,
HELP CENTER,
AWAY FROM IT.
>> Daryl: IS BUMPED OFF,
FOLLOWING UP IS BOARDS.
AS SOON
PAVELSKI.
PULLS AND SENDS THE
HUSTLES AFTER THEM IN FIRST
HALF OF THE FIRST PERIO
PRETTY SHOT, TOUGH SPOT, OVER
THE PAD BY THE BACK.
NATHAN BOWYER RETURNING FOR
THEN A COLLISION IN FRONT OF THE
JETS BENCH.
DILLON FROM FROM THEIR OWN
SUTER, BACKHANDELS MINOR HOCKEY.
>> Josh: THE BROTHERS, FATHER .
WHEELER'S GOT THE LONE GOALTING
>> Josh: ONE GOAL IN
TRYING FOROR LIKE THEY FLAILED
LITTLE
ONLY THE WINGS AHEAD OF THEM.
IF YOU HANDLE THAT.
THAT WAS JUST A WET BAG OF
CEMENT ON OETTINGER.
>> Daryl: SCHMIDT WAS TRYING TO
WAIT FOR SOMEBODY TO GET PETERS.
TONINATO.
FOR KLINGBERG.
LOOKING FOR
TRAPEZOID, LEFT WING SIDE,
SCHEIFELE.
PIONK FROM THE THE P BLOCKED
SHOTS IN FRONT OF HIM.
COMMITMENT WAS FRONT AND IS
BENN.
NO PANEL, BENN DOESN'T WEAR A V
OF THE FEW THAT DOESN'T.
DANGEROUSLY TO POGANSKI.
FOOT RACE, KLINGBERG AND THEN T
BREAKTHROUGH COMES.
GAME TIED UP WITH UNDER 6:30 TO
PLAY. NETMINDER.
>> Daryl: PRIOR TO THAT, HINTZ
HEAD UP.
I CAN BEAT YOU TO HEISKANEN.
HO.
>> Josh: HE WILL WATCH FROM BY .
HAD OETTINGER GOING WRONG
DIRECTION BUT LONG RIG